one big mistake as an entrepreneur can
cost you millions of dollars momentum
and years of lost time and the reason
why I tell you this because a lot of
time marketers when you think my
marketers there are a lot of mistakes
you can make as a marketer by the way if
you're an entrepreneur CEO guess what
else you are you are somewhat of a
marketer because at the beginning when
you're building your company as a
founder you may not know it but your
marketing whether it's directly or
indirectly you're marketing yourself and
you don't ever want as a marketer to
have a bipolar personality just like
individuals sometimes one day we're
happy when they were upset one day where
this one day with that sometimes you see
some brands they're so bipolar they're
all over the place they don't even know
what it is it's almost like a kid that
wants to try to please everybody and the
highest form of maturity is when one
becomes independent of others opinions
meaning you as a CEO you as an
entrepreneur need to position yourself
and realize who you want to be in
sticking to it here's why the biggest
mistake marketers will make is trying to
appeal to every single customer and you
just can't do that
because no one has yet done it and
become massively big because you just
can't do it now why is that let's talk
about a little bit for you doing some
what it is look there's really four
different categories you can choose to
be as an entrepreneur and as a business
let me explain on this side we have high
quality meaning the higher you are here
represents the better quality of a
product you have here if you're further
on the pendulum here means you're low
cost cost more expensive less expensive
better quality lower quality so if your
product is right here it means you're
what low cost low quality if your
product Falls here your high quality
high cost if you're here quality side
the cost is low and if you're here your
quality is low and cost the sign now
some people must have a path they can't
I just be everywhere no you can't it's
very simple Harvard is here a community
college is here public education may be
here but some places if you go and live
- I don't know how many times kids I
want to try to get my kids into Plano
West Plano area
because it has a great what high-quality
education but what low-cost that's still
a bracket you're going into you go into
certain areas public schools gonna be
here you're going some private schools
and maybe up here it doesn't matter what
the product is I can go into different
products let's look at it over here now
I wanna do tests with you Ferrari think
about it which of these four categories
you think Ferrari falls under a low
quality high cut low quality low cost No
low quality it's not low quality so we
know automatically it's not here is that
high quality yes do we know it's high
quality high cost yes Ferraris right
here
how about Starbucks you pay five dollars
for cappuccino whatever you want to call
a Frappuccino so quite a cost that's
high and quality at least that's what
they claim and if their quality wasn't
that high there wouldn't be as big as
they are today so they must have great
quality if we go to Tesla what do you
think Tesla is it's Tesla very very
expensive so you may say no the cost is
not really that high but the quality is
high
so maybe Tesla's here maybe test last
year because you can get a Tesla
nowadays what would Elan musk his goal
is to try to produce a product that's a
middle America product with a very very
high quality he wants to go here that's
his goal he's not trying to be Ferrari
he wants to be here high quality low
cost where is Walmart think about
Walmart you think Walmart cares that
they're here Walmart's the biggest
company in the world Walmart doesn't
care if you don't like Walmart Walmart
knows we're not gonna sell $6,000 Canali
suits and we're okay with that you're
not gonna go to Walmart and say I would
like to buy some ferragamo shoes they're
gonna say I'm sorry you want what kind
of shoes we got a Faro Jack shoe for
$9.99 you're getting no ferragamo shoes
here I like to get some Ferragamo bills
Pharaoh Pharaoh what Pharaoh
we have Pharaoh bills eleven dollars no
fair if we get the Gamo we have the
Pharaoh bills you're just not gonna get
that and that's where Walmart plays and
by the way they have 2.2 million
employees around the world so if you
sound like Walmart they don't care if
you like him that's where they are
Jaguar some people say what super why'd
you put Jaguar on there because Jaguar
is low quality high cost before they
became forward for many years
everybody would make fun of Jaguar
because Jaguar wanted to be this
high-end lug
jury card that you pay $60,000 to drive
or $55,000 $80,000 to drive and it
looked good but the quality just wasn't
that good you just it was very expensive
low quality until Ford bought Jaguar
then they change their repetition into
what they are right now if they didn't
it would be still here by the way I kill
with me what I care would probably be
low quality low cost I care would like
to say we're here but they're here now
for myself when we started a company I
started off myself as Morgan Stanley
Dean Witter now watch this when I
started with Morgan standing thing what
I just want to tell you this the
clientele you dealt would have Morgan's
to anything with over who people that
needed that had a net worth of a million
dollars and up so I'm dealing purely
here our fees were higher but I'm also
up here then I want to trans then I
start at PHP with our friends we start a
PHP agency our goal was to be high
quality our goal was to be high quality
low cost this is where we want it to be
we want to provide the highest quality
products out there with the lowest
amount of cost that works for us now
anytime you create an identity anytime
you create an identity once you create
an identity you have a reputation of
what your product is when you have a
reputation of what your product is and
all of a sudden you decide to change it
guess who you throw off your existing
base of customers because here's what
happens the father is well you know what
if we try to appeal to these guys we'll
also do a very very good job then
imagine how much money we could do
because it makes sense right common
sense wise you know we need to get
everybody because it just makes a lot of
sense really let me tell you a little
bit of history there used to be a time
there was competition for cigarettes
many many years ago you had Marlboro
camel and Winston who were competing
very close if you remember camel was
about what how cool they want it to be
all this other stuff and Winston was
coming up all these things in Marlboro
okay what ended up happening during this
period camel and Winston fell for market
manipulation media criticism all this
stuff and this is what the market did to
then media did media tow
Winston camel and Marlboro you know what
your mistake is you don't appeal to a
woman how was a big believe it you're
watching this run us in power what are
you talking about go study it you don't
appeal to women people are not attract
to Marlboro Winston and camel and we
believe these are consultants those who
know everything right we believe if you
try to start appealing to women you're
gonna crush it and the first one to do
that is gonna blow up really so guess
what happens
camel and Winston fell for it they
started having girls smoking cigarettes
and commercials they start having girls
holding cigarettes and magazines they
start having all these pretty girls
smoking cigarettes and they said oh
we're gonna get it we're so smart
Marlboro is not moving they don't move
they don't move they don't move and
guess what ended up happening they never
moved Marlboro didn't move Barbara
didn't fall for anything because
Marlboro made a decision a long time ago
Marlboro is a cigarette this is how they
aren't they're completely ok with that
Marlboro is a cigarette for man's man
that's their mo while everybody told
them to switch they didn't do it now
watch what happened to me give you some
numbers here today in the marketplace
Winston has 2% of the market
tamo has 8% of market Newport has 13
percent of the market and let me tell
you what
Marlo's got let me see let me tell you
here so we got Winston one to eight
thirteen you know what Marlboros got 41
percent goes to Marlborough you know why
here's why
now it's cigarettes by the way just so
you know the brand alone Marlboro if you
want to divide it's eighty eighty
billion dollars if you buy it today
last year 391 billion barbarous
cigarettes were smoked last year let me
say it again 391 billion cigarettes I
don't smoke cigarettes I can't stand
cigarette
there's nothing about cigarettes I like
my family they were smokers
I cannot stand cigarettes to save my
life I'll smoke for cigars per year and
that's pretty much it cannot stand the
smell of cigarettes
41% why they stuck to their product so
the question comes back to you here this
is me and you talking now
adios I got the question for you who is
your ideal customer who is your ideal
customer are you trying to please
everybody can you imagine if Morgan
Stanley one day says yes our ideal
client is a network of five million
dollars with a million dollars of
investable cash oh and by the way you
can also do $50 a month with Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter what are you talking
about that I go to the bank to do that I
go somewhere to open up a CD you want to
do that no way they lose their identity
and by the way so many companies do this
so if you're a smaller company you're
thinking okay you know I just mean this
so you're not there's so many people
because they see the potential of the
market and they want everything it is
very important what if Walmart look how
confusing this could be I want you to
think about Walmart makes an
announcement next year and this one
Walmart says effective January 1st 2017
Walmart will start selling Ferragamo and
Canale suits what would you say if
Walmart said that tell me you wouldn't
be confused and by the way do you think
the customers that go to Neiman Marcus
which is high quality high cost you
think they would go into Walmart to go
buy those Canali suits do you know how
confusing it is it's very confusing very
very confusing it's the same to save
Neiman Marcus decided to say we're
selling $9 you know shoes coming yet
it's just not gonna happen so who's your
ideal customer you you gotta ask the
question do you know it age bracket
income range what are they doing what
are they like why do they come to you
who is your product
what do you marketing your product to
and then stick to it and do whatever you
can to compete in that space and be the
best in that space so your biggest
differentiator could be Neiman Marcus
and Nordstrom's is here we are here and
we're happy with that we are here we're
happy with that you can go here we're
going over here target likes to say
target is whatever but guess what target
is not as low-cost as Walmart is and by
the way here's your part to keep in mind
about this
once you decide who your ideal customers
and once you decide where you want to
position yourself don't let
confuse you you will have enemies you
will have opposition you will have
people that are say terrible idea he has
no clue what he's doing she has no idea
what he's done
everyone's gonna try to confuse you and
if you can stick to the message long
enough you'll succeed if you can't
you're like the rest of the
entrepreneurs and marketers out there
that made the mistake of trying to
appeal to everybody and lost every
single thing they had and they lost
their success millions and they went
from a market where they were competing
with Marlboro and then all of a sudden
they drop drop drop drop drop neither a
2% Winston Winston in Iran was Winston
no Winston is 2% camel used to be very
famous today 8% Marvel 41% stick to your
message for his longest period market is
strong until all of a sudden you become
one the competitors everyone says oh my
gosh they're so smart over there it's
not that you're smart just highest form
of maturity is when you become
independent of others opinions and
others opinions is everybody telling you
what to do stay focused on what you want
to be and who you want to be and where
your ideal customers are going to be
would that be instead let's get that
pillow here hey I was excited about
doing this episode very excited about
doing this episode because I get this
message all the time Pat I want to get
this customer that customer this video
is dedicated to all of you that say I
want to get all the more when I ask you
who's your customer you say everybody I
disconnect because you can't have
everybody as your custom you got to know
exactly who your customer is ok first
things first if you haven't stopped
please do so click on the sub button
here and by the way I think YouTube's
got a new thing now that sub doesn't
send notifications anymore so be sure to
stop you know right next to it you see
like an alert button click on that as
well because you're the first to get
notifications then very soon I'm going
to be doing certain things for those who
comment first and watch the videos first
so you want to make sure you subscribe
and you get the alerts before anybody
else because our goal is to get 2
million subs before 2018 meaning right
now at 16 we're about to be 17 in a
couple weeks by the end of 2017 we want
this channel to be out of million subs I
know a lot of people say it's crazy we
just cross 155 thousand subs right now
paddy got 845 more to go
how do you think this is gonna happen 1
no one thought we were gonna get 200,000
subs when we were at 2,000 steps but you
helped us get there and there are a lot
of people that don't then we'll
two million subs but we feel you're
gonna help us get there and we will make
one promise to you we will keep creating
the best content online for
entrepreneurs and you will always judge
us based on our content we will
constantly work on creating best content
online for entrepreneurs and as long as
we do our job and you help us out we can
proudly get two million subs by the end
of 2017 with your help and with our
effort with that being said if you got
any questions thoughts comment comment
on the bottom thanks for watching
everybody take care alright one big
mistake as an entrepreneur can cost you
yours of lost time yours a lost time
that proper English you cannot please
every single customer oh please that
might be flirting by the time we're done
shooting but I got to shooting the video
and a steamer right now one big mistake
as an entrepreneurs can cost you
millions of dollars for momentum okay